Can I help you i'm looking for a mandalorian
well we don't get many visitors in these parts
can you describe him someone who looks like me
you mean to marshall your marshall wears
mandalorian armor huh see for yourself
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new mandalorian season 2 episode 1 video
congratulations you made it we finally have
new episodes i'll be doing videos for all
the episodes this season so be sure to subscribe
to get all those we'll do a giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your favorite wtf
moment from the episode on the video or favorite
easter egg careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet and everything from
season one there were a ton of easter eggs that
we have to cover so we'll do top 10 wtf and just
easter eggs throughout the episode as we go along
starting with number 10 the title of the episode
the marshall as a reference to cobb vance
character played by timothy olyphant who's kind
of doing a version of his seth bullock character
from deadwood he also even used a similar
accent that he used on the deadwood series
if you haven't seen that series it's amazing
but it's western like the mandalorian is a space
western so a lot of the references do carry over
pretty nicely but the opening scene starts with
amanda and baby yoda walking up into town in the
middle of the night there's graffiti everywhere
reminding everyone of sabine ren's graffiti from
star wars rebels everyone wondering if she's going
to show up during the series because ahsoka is
supposed to show up as baby yoda looks around
you see all these red eyes start to light up you
notice the graffiti has a lot of easter eggs in
it too the artist who did this is named david cho
he's actually famous in real life for doing this
type of graffiti art he has a big cameo as one of
the spectator aliens during the big fighting ring
scene a little bit after this you notice a bunch
of white images of helmets those are obviously
meant to signify stormtroopers you notice yellow
for c3po easter eggs there's a blue aqualish
face that stands out pretty prominently and then
above the door here before he goes in you see a
toydarian face like watto's face in a gamorrean
face because obviously they're fighting in the
ring number nine the gamorrean fighting ring so
as he goes and he's looking for someone called
gore koresh the twilight bouncer greets
him outside this is actually a character
actor that's shown up in a lot of the marvel
movies so you may recognize him from somewhere
as he walks down to the ring though you notice
all the banners above the fighting ring those are
just for the territories in and around the outer
rim planets because he makes a lot of references
to mandalorians hiding out in different
clans like his clan was hiding out on nevarro
i'm still trying to identify every single alien
here in the fighting ring some of them are a
little more obvious than others so if you know
who some of the more obscure aliens are be sure
to write them below in the comments but a lot
of these aliens you'll notice are aliens that
appeared during jabba's palace at some part
during return of the jedi because even though
they're referencing a lot of different star wars
series and movies during each of the episodes
this episode in particular for a number of reasons
heavily referenced return of the jedi because of
a couple characters that showed up during
the episode and them going back to tatooine
david cho the graffiti artist in this cameo
here seems like he's meant to be a nick doe
here's a toilet also from jabba's palace baby yoda
just seems absolutely fascinated by the fighting
as they're walking around panning around all these
different creatures the gorr koresh character that
he was speaking to during all the trailer footage
with the one eye is an abyssin they're native to
byss in the deep core there was a planet featured
during the dark empire comics where emperor
palpatine stored all his clones they kind of tried
to reference that with all the clones that showed
up on exogol during rise of skywalker but a lot
of people heard his voice during the trailer
wondering who he was is the celebrity cameo for
sure but i wouldn't have known who it was unless
i looked in the credits it's john leguizamo he
changed his voice quite a bit and they processed
it to make it sound even more different so if
you didn't guess that it was him don't feel bad
but during their conversation he's trying to
find other mandalorians so that they can help him
find any of the jedi that survived order 66 in
the purge they remind you about what happened
to the mandalorians and they remind you of that
scene in season 1 episode 8 where they find the
pile of bescar armor and all of his dead comrades
he references killing other mandalorians and
taking their best car because its price is rising
it's becoming more valuable in the galaxy as it
becomes more scarce they do the big whistling bird
scene from the trailer baby yoda closing his shell
which is kind of funny he throws his vibro blade
into the zabrak here which is the race that darth
maul comes from he takes out the twilight and then
after he strings up gor koresh he tells him that
the only mandalorian that he knows about is back
on tatooine so everyone's like wait a minute are
they talking about boba fett obviously this is
all set up for cobb vance in that big twist he
also makes a reference to the gotra he swears by
the gotra that's actually a reference to a group
called the droid gatro which is an organization
that they introduced during the grand moff tarkin
book from 2014 in the aftermath novel series
also where cobb vanth appeared for the first time
that group is made up of a bunch of repurposed
battle droids left over from the clone wars who
are advocating for droid emancipation they're
based mostly on coruscant so i don't know if
they're going to bring that group up later this
season or if that was just meant to be a one-off
reference but he tells him he needs to go to
mos pelgos a city on tatooine so number eight
return to tatooine with a bunch of return of the
jedi easter eggs like i said a lot of return of
the jedi references during the episode because
they're returning to tatooine return of the jedi
you can make all the baby yoda jedi mandalorian
jokes you want the yo delorean he is kind of the
future of the jedi order and because he's part
of the mandalorians clan tangentially you could
also consider baby yoda a mandalorian right now
there's always been a lot of people ever since
season one that have theorized that the title of
the series the mandalorian is actually a reference
to baby yoda not to din jaron but he goes back to
the exact same most highly spaceport remember the
docking port that he lands in is the same one
that the millennium falcon was docked in during
a new hope amy sodaris character comes back from
season one and they bring back the repair droids
from phantom menace she calls baby yoda a womp rat
there are a lot of womp rat references during the
episode too she makes a joke about him liking
droids now but that's just a reference to what
happened with ig-11 in the season one finale
saving them by sacrificing himself so the
mando kind of respects some droids now he makes
another reference to the network of coverts around
the outer rim territories the smaller pockets of
mandalorian clans that are hiding out like his was
that might wind up leading us to ahsoka to
katie sakhoff's bokeh tan crease character
they're just letting you know that there are a
lot of other mandalorians hiding around the galaxy
that we'll run into throughout this season
and future seasons they bring back r5 from a
new hope i believe it's supposed to be the same
r5 unit she brings up the map of tatooine from
before the war they reference mos eisley most espa
again then most pelgo is just meant to be an old
mining settlement that collapsed after the fall of
the empire you get the big full backstory once you
meet cobb vance character though he takes the same
speeder bike from season one episode five but this
time baby yoda is riding in his back on the pouch
he stops to talk to more tuscan raiders who are
roasting what seems like a kawakian monkey
lizard that's the salacious crumb creature
we saw some of those roasting on spits during
season one as he continues through the desert
he passes a giant bantha skeleton which is a nice
callback to the krait dragon skeleton from a new
hope and obviously a lot of those references
to the crate dragon go back to a new hope
the small rodent creatures that scurry away as
he rides into town are literally called scurriers
they're featured during attack of the clones when
anakin skywalker comes back to save his mother
you see a bunch of moisture farming towers just a
lot of familiar structures and architecture from
other parts of tatooine in the star wars movies
then number seven the mandalorian meets cobb vanth
so there's a weak way bartender another return of
the jedi reference he's a celebrity cameo it's w
earl brown who was also on the dead woods series
with timothy olyphant the weak way is just another
alien that was working on jabba's sail barge
during luke skywalker's rescue of han solo
and leia above the sarlacc pit very relevant to
this episode when they go to take down the crate
dragon referencing the sarlacc and because
of the big boba fett twist at the end of the
episode just as baby yoda peeks his head around
the corner and they make the reference to the
marshall showing up they give you the full reveal
he walks in in boba fett's armor and obviously it
doesn't seem like boba fett so even if you didn't
know who the cobb band character was right away
you kind of knew that this probably wasn't boba
fett he gives himself away though when he orders
two shots of spochka that's the same drink that's
made from the krill that they were farming during
season one episode four so the show is already
starting to reference itself i love the mando's
reaction though when he takes his helmet off so
that he can drink mando's so surprised that he
just stopped dead in his tracks like what the hell
just happened why did you take your helmet off
immediately it gives him away as being a
non-mandalorian what are you doing with that armor
take it off right now or i will take it off of you
they have a very han versus greedo who shot first
gunslinger standoff moment foreshadowing eventual
gunslinger standoff between the mando and boba
fett like they're building towards a good the bad
and the ugly talking about western references the
three-way standoff with mando moff gideon and boba
fett i guess mando would be the good moff gideon
would be the bad and boba fett would be the ugly
in that situation but they're stopped short by the
ground tremor caused by the crate dragon so number
six the great krait dragon hunt in the return of
the jedi flashback scene the way they play the
krait dragon reveal is a little bit like the dune
series with the sand worms it travels underneath
the earth instead of on top of it but cobb banth
agrees to give him boba fett's armor if he helps
kill the crate dragon because the crate dragon has
been terrorizing this area for a long long time i
love the way he referenced the second death star
too when he's talking about his backstory so they
flash back to the end of return of the jedi and
they're watching the explosion of the second
death star on the hollow net then he says the
mining consortium just moved in in the vacuum left
by the empire and took over town as he runs out to
escape you may recognize the speeder from a new
hope he also talks about the cam tono they bring
that back from season one which is basically the
ice cream maker from empire strikes back he finds
the crystals which he then trades to the jaws for
boba fett's armor but not before they try to pawn
off a couple other star wars easter eggs on him
so there's the r2 unit that just colored a little
bit differently then you probably recognize this
droid's head from a new hope when c-3po wakes up
inside the sand crawler it's based on the original
designs for c3po and ralph mcquarrie's concept art
but that's when cobb vance then came back to town
becoming the quote-unquote marshall just getting
rid of the mining consortium and helping the
people you also probably spotted that the speeder
bike that he was using is actually salvaged parts
from a pod racer from phantom menace but not just
any pod racer this is actually taken from anakin
skywalker's pod racer now that's pod racing but my
other favorite easter egg here about boba fett's
armor is actually a big callback to the star wars
holiday special the first appearance of the boba
fett character was during the star wars holiday
special and it was because they were going to
create a toy to sell it actually had a rocket
launcher that you could fire just pressing a
little button but because their lawyers were
concerned that children would choke on the rocket
that you could fire out of the boba fett toy they
had to recall it so almost nobody got their hands
on that particular toy it's actually a pretty big
collector's item if you have one and if you guys
didn't know other big star wars holiday special
goings on they did a brand new one that they're
gonna drop before thanksgiving that's right jon
favreau joked about doing a new star wars holiday
special last year they actually did it and we're
gonna see it in a couple weeks number five the
redemption of the tuscan raiders after attack
of the clones he uses a tuscan raider call to
call them out and get the creatures to submit
they reveal they also want to get rid of the
crate dragon so they want to team up they go back
to their encampment and you actually learn that
they're way more chill than they appeared during
episode 2 attack of the clones most of what we
know about the tuscan raiders are from a new hope
when they just go ham on luke skywalker
and he has to be saved by obi-wan kenobi
then attack of the clones when they capture and
kill anakin skywalker's mother and he winds up
killing the entire village all the women all the
children post all your anakin skywalker memes
they were pretty obvious about wanting to redeem
them as characters during the episode the mando
trying to bridge that gap like no no no you have
to work together or this isn't gonna happen he
really really loves using that flamethrower i
think he almost used it in every single episode
of season one we'll see if that trend continues in
season two number four the mandalorian versus the
krait dragon round one so the lair of the crate
dragon might give you flashbacks to the mudhorn
battle from episode two but the crate dragon is
living in an abandoned sarlacc pit they make a
joke about the crate dragon eating a sarlacc
and then you kind of get a picture for how big
it actually is baby yoda starts freaking out when
he senses the crate dragon coming there wasn't a
whole lot of baby yoda going on during the episode
they really just cut to him every once in a while
for a reaction shot but when they're explaining
all this they also kind of imply what happened
with boba fett so because they're close to the
original sarlacc pit from return of the jedi
they're also kind of implying that's part of how
boba fett escaped the sarlacc the krait dragon
may have attacked or eaten the sarlacc that he was
in and he may have just used that chaos to escape
i love the fact that it doesn't take the
bait the crate dragon itself actually seems
really intelligent the way it tries to fight
them especially later in the episode then mando
sets up the alliance with the townspeople so they
have to partner up with the tuscan raiders that
they've been fighting and killing this entire
time that's another theme of the mandalorian
season 2 really the whole show former adversaries
working together to defeat a common enemy that's
even worse like say moth gideon for instance like
all the different clans of mandalorians hiding out
in the galaxy banding back together to take down
moff gideon they make a reference to the dune c
really anytime you're on tatooine everything that
they reference has something to do with either a
new hope or return of the jedi then number three
the mandalorian versus the crate dragon round two
so this time they're able to get it out of its
cave just a little bit it takes a while to get
it into place but it starts spewing its bile all
over them and it turns out it's really acidic they
really upgraded a lot of their action sequences
they have that really cool scene with mando and
cob van using their jet packs to get up close and
then maneuver around cobb banth pretty good with
that jet pack for not being a mandalorian he uses
boba fett's rocket launcher again to position the
krait dragon so that mando can let himself get
eaten with the bantha and all the charges to
take it down from the inside so number two now the
mando has acquired boba fett's armor and is just
gonna be on the razor crest obviously that's gonna
come back in later episodes very important detail
he also says hopefully we'll meet again and
that's just a reference to him coming back
and cameoing in a future episode potentially but
as you notice the tuscan raiders picking through
the carcass of the crate dragon they find the
krait dragon's pearl which is basically priceless
in of course number one wtf moment the big boba
fett ending scene reveal so as mando is riding
across the sunset in the landscape at the end of
the episode they reveal he's being watched from
a vantage point by boba fett who's not wearing
his armor clearly recognizable as tamura morrison
he seems like he notices the mandalorian
wearing his armor and sees that he has his
armor like he's probably been tracking cobb van
trying to take his armor back i don't know how
many episodes he's supposed to be in obviously at
least one more big episode but probably a little
bit more than that i think the pitch is that he
might become a bigger character in season three
john favreau wrote most of the episodes but dave
filoni get this wrote and directed episode 5 so
that's best odds when ahsoka tano is gonna appear
for the first time she's being played by rosario
dawson but they've been really quiet and been
holding way back on revealing what's going on
with her during season two but my mandalorian
season 2 episode 2 video will post next friday
it'll be the same schedule for all the episodes
this season and i will do more bonus videos for
boba fett ahsoka and the bigger easter eggs
and teasers week to week so just leave all
your mandalorian video requests in the comments
for things you want me to make videos about
i'll name a giveaway winner when i post my
next star wars video click here for my full
star wars mandalorian season 2 trailer video and
click here for all my mandalorian episode videos
thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe this is the way!